pierre-emmanuel thomann professeur en
géopolitique et fondateur d'euro
continent qu'un manuel thomann bonjour
et merci d'être avec nous en direct sur
rt france à la première question comment
londres at elle pu violer l'accord du
pas de site londres selon le point de
vue l'union européenne donc à violer
l'accord de break site en accordant aux
sociétés britanniques le droit de ne pas
opérer de contrôles aux frontières entre
le territoire britannique et l'irlande
du nord
il faut savoir que le dilemme pour les
britanniques
puisqu'ils ont voté pour le breakbeat
ces deux ans après les négociations avec
l'union européenne qui a vu voulu
préserver son marché unique
c'est soit de effectué un contrôle entre
la frontière et en irlande du nord et
l'irlande soit un contrôle entre la
grande bretagne et l'irlande du nord
mais sachant que l'irlande du nord fait
partie du royaume uni il était évident
que les britanniques vont avant tout
défendre leur l'unité territoriale du
pays est en pleine crise de co vide
ils ne veulent pas soumettre les
sociétés britanniques à des tracasseries
supplémentaires mais derrière celle ci
ces disputes sur les accords du brésil
il y à l'enjeu de la souveraineté
c'est-à-dire que les britanniques ont
voté pour le brésil où elle s'ouvre et
c'est à dire décider eux mêmes sur
quelque part comment comment ils vont se
comporter vis-à-vis de leur politique
commerciale aussi de leurs normes
évidemment l'union européenne qui défend
le marché unique veut montrer qu'il ya
une différence
pour un pays qui sort de l'union
européenne et que si le psy dans cet
accord debré exit ont fait les
britanniques ont tenu un bon accord je
pense puisque dix longs il n'y a pas de
droits de douane pour les produits mais
néanmoins qu'ils doivent se soumettre
aux normes européennes
et si les britanniques ne se soumettent
pas aux normes européennes
évidemment petit à petit d'autres dans
d'autres états membres
on va on va remarquer que si l'on peut
participer au marché unique mais sans
les normes et en tout en restant
souverain à quoi sert réellement de
faire partie de l'union européenne donc
il ya une lutte de pouvoir et
d'influencé entre le royaume européenne
il était évident a appelé les acteurs
sur le sur le brésil la part des
disputes très très difficile en clair de
détail et me pose la question
on sait par les conséquences de ces
procédures que souhaite lancer l'union
européenne peuvent elles porter
préjudice à l'union européenne plus que
au royaume uni alors il est assez
étonnant lorsqu'on compare les accords
commerciaux avec l'accord de brigit avec
le royaume uni et les accords
commerciaux au niveau mondial que
l'union européenne soit 6 regardante
avec le royaume le royaume uni est alors
que dans des accords avec la chine ou
les états unis il ya des violations
beaucoup plus grande et l'union
européenne est moins regardant parce que
son idéologie c'est le libre échange les
frontières ouvertes mais avec les
britanniques
il essaye d'être plus dur parce que ils
veulent montrer aux autres états membres
qu'il est difficile de sortir de l'union
européenne alors c'est un rapport de
force et nous allons voir où chacun de
chacun des partenaires jusqu'où ils sont
prêts à aller mais je pense que
les britanniques ont obtenu un meilleur
accord qu'on ne croit il faut voir ça
cela dans la durée ils ont obtenu leur
souveraineté
et c'est cela qui est difficile pour
l'union européenne
accepter qu'un état membre reprenne sa
souveraineté car l'union européenne
évidemment veut en terme de pouvoir
aimerait par son idéologie normative
contrôler ses propres états membres est
toujours élargir son influence est donc
c'est cela qu'on qu'il va être
intéressant de voir au final qui va
mieux s'en sortir mais je pense que les
britanniques maintenant se considère
comme souverain et il sera difficile de
les empêcher de prendre des décisions
souveraines et surtout que les l'union
européenne en fait avec la sortie du
royaume uni perd de l'influencé je pense
que c'est surtout l'union européenne qui
va qui va perdre de l'influencé dans le
monde à cause de la sortie du royaume
uni d'eau qu'elle sera au final obligé
de faire des concessions
merci beaucoup en tout cas pierre
emmanuel thomas d'avoir réagi avec nous
en direct ce matin sur rtl france je
rappelle que vous êtes fondateur d'euro
continuer le professeur en géopolitique